i trapped the devil was written and
directed by joshua lobo and was put out
by IFC midnight last weekend the same
day that Avengers end game came out so
that's unfortunate for a small indie
horror film and this film tells the
story of a man named Steve played by
Scott Poythress who's locked himself
away during the holidays in his home and
when his brother unexpectedly arrives at
his house he begins to question Steve
about his paranoia because he's acting
very strange he's holding a revolver he
seems to have a secret about something
in his basement and eventually he admits
that he believes he's trapped the devil
himself down there and the majority of
the film takes place in this house and
Lobo tries to do his best to make use of
all of the rooms in the setting to
heighten as much paranoia and read as he
can with a very limited budget
now I must be upfront before I get any
farther in the review I do know some
members of this production personally
and that's not gonna affect this review
at all I told them I would be completely
honest with how I felt and most artists
want that they don't want you to
sugarcoat things just because you know
them they don't want you to pretend like
something they did was perfect when it
wasn't they want you to be honest I've
seen the film twice and on first viewing
what I appreciated the most about it is
that it relies very much so on Dredd
they didn't have a lot at their disposal
when it came to budget this is a very
small indie horror film and so they do
their best to build as much suspense as
possible this is a very actor friendly
film this is an opportunity for actors
to really shine because the movie does
kind of come off like a stage play since
it takes place just about entirely in
one house and it's these three
characters shifting from room to room
and having paranoid conversations about
the other person and whether or not he's
insane is the devil really downstairs in
this basement trapped by a cross or has
he kidnapped some poor man off the
street
this gives the actors a real opportunity
here and Scott poythress as the lead
Steve just Rises to that opportunity he
is by far the best aspect of this movie
and I think a real find he's done things
before his IMDB lists him as being
supporting characters in various TV
shows and films but
this movie is front and center Scott
Poythress and I thought he was
remarkable in the movie and Poythress is
really good especially at delivering
exposition and making it feel realistic
because he does have to say a few things
to explain just a couple things so we
can kind of get up to speed and he does
it with such ease he has this nervous
twitchiness to him that just really sold
his characters disposition he's easily
my favorite part of the film the score
by Ben Lovett is pretty chilling as well
what Josh Lobo does very well with this
movie is keep it as contained as
possible and I know the strain he was
under when making it I'm aware of his
budgetary restraints I'm aware of issues
he had and getting it made and I also
know that he had nine days to shoot this
movie which is insane anyone will tell
you that nine days to shoot a feature is
that's just horrifying to give you a
perspective I shot my short film
auditorium six which ended up being
about thirty minutes long in like five
and a half days and even then we felt
like we had just enough time so that
should give you an idea of the type of
strain that they were under when making
this movie which does affect
unfortunately the pacing and some of the
scenes because some aspects of it do
feel very rushed there are scenes that
take place all in one take where
sometimes that could be really awesome
and you can tell it's what the director
wanted here sometimes it feels like it
was done out of necessity like we have
to do this all in one take and you guys
just please nail your lines and we'll do
this and we'll move on so sometimes the
movie can feel rushed because you can
tell they when they were just running
out of time there are also performances
that aren't always as on as I think Lobo
perhaps would have wanted them to be
because you can only do so many takes
and you got to move on and so that there
isn't a lot of leeway really here a film
like this really could have benefited
from like a 15 16 day shoot to elongate
that and to give them more breathing
room because you can tell you can tell
that it was done really quickly which
doesn't
always work for the movie but what will
turn audience members off the most here
is that it is a very slow burn film and
the the phrase slow burn I've mentioned
in the past can be an insult for boring
and there are scenes in the movie that
just don't work as well as they wanted
them to and you can tell that sometimes
the payoff just wasn't quite there for
things that were set up at the same time
it does seem like they were trying to
make a movie with as little exposition
as possible which is Noble but sometimes
you do need that you have it's it's
always a balance it's it's how much do
you put in your movie and how much do
you to trust your audience and Lobo
trust the audience completely which can
be hard because a lot of people go to
horror movies expecting to be shocked
expecting to be thrilled and this movie
isn't interested in that this film just
wants to be suspenseful it sets up a
mystery which I don't see enough of
anymore in horror I I don't see enough
of this type of filmmaking when you have
a story that sounds cool but there's
nothing much else to do with it besides
have characters sit in the house and
talk about it during Christmas it
automatically puts you into that niche
sub-genre of horror where it's got a
Christmas theme which is rare but at the
same time it's like let's get going
let's see what else can happen and
audiences can sometimes be disappointed
when not a lot happens you can call this
psychological horror and it is in a way
but to me this is more like
contemplative horror it's people
presented with a scenario and then they
had to figure out what they're going to
do and we get to watch them figure out
and hopefully they do it in a way that's
entertaining for an audience that being
said this film is not aiming to
entertain an audience I really do not
think it is this film is trying and
sometimes too hard to be drastically
different from everything else on the
market it takes a lot of risks there
isn't a lot of payoff and a lot of
questions are purposefully left
unanswered and that is going to anger
the out of some audience members I
feel like this could be one of those
horror films that critics definitely
appreciate more than your average
audience member so whether or not you
like this film is going to rely entirely
on what you watch a horror movie for in
fact in many ways this movie isn't
exactly a horror movie it's more of a
dark drama
the original title listed on IMDB is a
man in the dark but it was later changed
to I trap the devil no doubt for
marketing purposes the original title is
a lot better that title speaks the film
that actually plays before your eyes way
better than I trap the devil does
because that sort of sets you up for
this visceral horrific experience of
intensity and that's not the film that
Lobo made this is a dark drama boosted
by an incredible performance by Scott
Poythress joseline Donaghy was also in
the film very briefly so don't go to the
film if you're expecting just to see her
if you're a fan of hers because she's
also brilliant but in the brief time
she's in the movie she's excellent as
she usually is now some people have
drawn comparisons to the Twilight Zone
episode the howling man and you should
it's very similar to that it feels like
it's taking that idea the themes
presented in that episode and really
expanding upon them whereas that episode
was only about 25 30 minutes long
this is feature-length and so it does
feel like a drag sometimes it's the
performances though for me that saved
the movie the cinematography and Lobos
sense of dread that he knows how to
create a sequence of scenes that make
you feel uneasy and that's the type of
horror that sometimes off puts audiences
when you go to a film and you just feel
kind of weird when you watch it it's not
like an entertaining weird you know what
I mean like sometimes the film will just
make you feel off and you're like whew
this is really cool I feel up
right now but this movie is
uncomfortable purposefully and so for
some that's not gonna work for me I like
a filmmaker that takes risks I like a
filmmaker that makes a horror film that
is absolutely opposed to your general
horror film you see and this film is it
has no interest in being like the other
things that are on the market and that's
what I liked about it I'm gonna give i
trapped the devil a b-minus
it's on VOD right now and in select
theaters I do suggest checking it out
especially if you want to support
filmmakers who are trying to make things
outside of the box outside of the norm
purposely subversive those are the types
of filmmakers I really want to support
because they usually get buried by the
big movies for instance Avengers endgame
which I love but still nobody really
talked about this movie last weekend and
I do think it's important to support
filmmakers who are trying to make things
different so guys thank you so much as
always for watching look forward to more
reviews very soon and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
[Music]
you